ahora veamos cómo pasar de una
representación decimal
si mal a una representación en binario
di nario aquí en este vídeo vamos a ver
cómo tomar un número en 10 email y
volver a escribirlo pero ahora en su
representación en binario pero vamos a
empezar por un ejemplo sencillo y
directo con un número no muy grande
vamos a empezar con el número
13 así es que te recomiendo que le
pongas pausa a este vídeo y trates de
escribir el número 13 en el sistema
binario bueno suponiendo que ya lo
intentaste el chiste para escribir al
cualquier número decimal en su
representación en binario es escribir a
este número como la suma de puras
potencias de 2 ok porque eso es
básicamente lo que hace la
representación binaria es decir cuáles
potencias de 2 tienes que sumar para
obtener este número
así es que pues vamos a empezar por
poner aquí todas las potencias de 2
bueno no todas sólo hasta que pasemos el
número 13 entonces tenemos aquí 2 a la 0
2 a la 01 2 a la 1 que es un 22 a las 2
que es 2 por 2 que es 42 a la 3 que es 4
por 28 2 a la 4 que es 8 por 2 16
y listo estas son todas las potencias de
2 que necesitamos para construir a 13
así es que lo que hacemos es buscar a la
potencia de 2 más grande que sea menor o
igual a 13 y resulta que esa es este
entonces vamos a escribir a 13 como la
suma de 8 más 5 ok el 8 si es una
potencia de 2 ahora el 5 no es una
potencia de 2 pero sí lo podemos
escribir como sumas de potencias de 2 o
keith queremos escribir a este 5 como la
suma de potencias de 2 así es que
buscamos a la potencia de 2 más grande
que sea menor o igual a 5 y esa pues es
este 4 entonces vamos a escribir a este
5 como cuatro más uno y listo porque
resulta que este uno es una potencia de
dos ok entonces ya logramos escribir a
13 como la suma de potentes
2 este 8 es 2 a la 3 este 4 es un 2
elevado a las 2 y este
uno es el 2 elevado a la potencia 0
ahora también podemos ver a esta suma
como la suma de un 81
y 11 y eso lo voy a poner así tal cual
como un 1 aunque hay el 13 es la suma de
18 + 14 + 11 y por qué es útil esta
representación del 13 pues porque con
esto básicamente ya estamos escribiendo
al 13 en representación binaria aunque a
ver vamos a regresar nos al mundo
binario a ver la primera cifra cuando
escribimos a un número en representación
binaria lo que representa es cuántos
unos hay en su representación binaria
cuántos unos tenemos que sumar para
construir a este número después para
pasar al siguiente lugar a la siguiente
cifra tenemos que multiplicar por 2
entonces este es el lugar de los doses
volvemos a multiplicar por 2 para llegar
a este lugar que es el lugar de los
cuatros
y volvemos a multiplicar por 2 y
llegamos al lugar de los hechos entonces
para saber que tengo que poner en la
primera cifra me voy a buscar en esta
representación cuantos unos tengo y
resulta que aquí tengo un 1 entonces
tenemos que poner por aquí un 1 después
me voy a buscar cuántos doses tengo pero
resulta que no tengo ningún 2 no o sea
tengo un 8 y tengo un 4 y tengo un 1
pero no tengo ningún 2
así es que pues voy a poner que tenemos
0 12 y continuamos ahora buscamos y
tenemos un 4
así es que ponemos que tenemos un 4 y
tenemos un 8 y listo
esta es la representación en binario del
número que en representación decimal es
si queremos escribir 13 en sistema
binario tenemos que poner 11